and I mentioned largely DF 6 this is a 6
and file subunit within data and
statistics and it's a really good one ok
I think it's a really cool sort of you
that check to be database
come on why are you surprised
this is one of the things which I feel
ridiculous that cheaters extension one
extension chooses they don't find out
about writing how long we can roll with
distribution and then say also notified
out of that I perfectly this is crazy
this is so important to the way that we
understand like the world around us that
it's a big like regular soap the sub
unit title is sent me a population these
are what you've heard the book separate
populations and they obviously relate to
each other plans close when we talk
about a stable can you help me remember
we've had a very very cursory look at
what tables are when you say I have a
sample of the population
what does that mean any takers yeah what
okay across sections are really good for
you eventually cross section I do trust
you that we'll be getting prisons right
you go prism and whole idea if I know
you get drawn well in this classroom we
get that word for a prism if you have a
prism and you take a cross section of
that prism who joins you in your color
the whole plate
excuse me of doing this on a prism in
that every cross section is identical
right so for you look we just Chuck one
good okay now the whole point of the
cross section in it represents it's like
one tiny little slice from which you can
generalize what the rest of the prism is
doing okay it's in things does that
exactly for population related
tended to okay but that leads to a
problem populations are not prisms
so when you take a simple what kinds of
problems arise we look at something
before in our previous students what
scholar can you get when you take a
sample it was just okay that's right it
was jump off there wins idea think about
for example if I chose for our school as
in the population if I said okay 12 mg 2
- that's my sample I'm going to ask you
guys a bunch of questions we'll take a
measurement to your 5 or whatever what
problems arise by treating you guys as
the simple yeah brilliant thing or
sitting in rows and Rizzoli's will write
in quad yep and so that's not very
immaculate sensation of the entire
school ok all right if you can sell
afraid it's really important for us all
to get out of there now y'all come to
your point which is that you want your
cross section to be an accurate
representation super important phrase of
your population right and we can think
are immediately problems by using our
class has an accurate representation
because what on the face of it we're all
from the same grade right so we've got 7
8 9 10 11 12 in the school so
immediately we run into problems as to
whether our class is an accurate
representation of the population now are
you going to raise a different point
first of all this is something we looked
at last year who said you've ever we see
you 223 and we had a look at the number
of students here we try to extrapolate
from that how many girls or boys there
would be in the whole school and our
numbers were totally up because it just
so happens within this class the
distribution of protocol is not at all
an accurate representation of the rest
of the school now this is a problem
because this is always going to be an
issue we've beat that really obvious
examples in terms of our class as a
sample but you can never get away from
this you can never get away from this
we try though what were some of the
techniques we use we said they're not
just simple there are different kinds of
samples and I'll try to draw
a picture for you to try and my life
stratifying random and systematic okay
very good so the words are come back
let's just drop those down to see if you
derivative um
systematic random satisfied okay no
grease on me okay down these were and
I'm not going to go back over them I
just want to remind you of these ideas
these are different ways to try and
solve this problem of a simple being you
know not always the most accurate
representation wallet what would it mean
to have a systematic representation
science it may be sample of a population
what could we do yet this is like bamboo
yep standing say you know restaurant at
the door and maybe every every xx person
that comes Park you ask them how did you
experience or something and so is that
every xx person of gauge for however
perfect yes and if this example also
came up in like factories right so we
want to check if all the light bulbs
were producing on a good quality or
defective or whatever so you check every
twenty at my club or something like that
right so we call this systematic because
it is highly structured it's highly
predictable and sometimes you can't do
anything else but get people as they go
through it's not like you're going to
get how people go to a back into the day
maybe a thousand people and like a big
one and so you kind of get all what does
it'll just say in a room for what okay
you can just Mack is you need to sit in
this room all day until I can randomly
pick out a bunch of you and make you my
sample okay that was it example ah what
is stratified example is when I drew
this picture about how much you take a
population what might cheer let's
actually think back to the you 12 issue
how could we overcome this this is a
specific example your dad how could we
get the stratified sample of the school
any suggestion like you've ever probably
got much anything
a Shinra joke you've got 100 people
stand the news for a 10-year sentence
and then you just like worked out for
fortune percentage of each grade
fantastic so you can see if you've got
different layers in your population and
you can identify which proportions they
are that you simply take an according
proportion of that little Brook and then
you put them all together and it's a
stratified sample because it has layers
to it which is what straight up means
layers fine now just let's rewind one
more step just to ask a big question
what are we doing samples in the first
place why this is a necessity why is
this so something that we can't we don't
really have a choice but to do honestly
you say it's a formative indices one
cheek sampling is a way to get a small
group of people because impractical to
do this otherwise right so this is a lot
of people going to opt out before we
have a go at our actual class today
simply is a compromise once you are
compromising between is the accuracy of
your results you're obviously not going
to have results that are inaccurate
first as compared to if you checked
everyone but what you're comparing that
to is resources like same time abundant
right it's cheaper and it's faster to do
this not submission oh what's the
alternative
what something innocent when you check
absolutely everyone it's called our
senses now we know we could do this we
know it's expensive so that's why we
don't do it very frequently but not only
that once you get census data like okay
Australia is how many million people 20
24 25 million people okay how long does
it think it takes you know the
government to get all that data and put
it to usable form after a long time and
actually if you're like 300 million like
the US or billions like India or China
once you get all of the information
right
you don't have a staff which has
everyone it just takes forever so maybe
in that information would be useful to
you by the time you actually get it okay
so therefore sampling is a really big
deal